a lot of people get tripped up at this
point because they've forgotten that
functions are just specialized objects
but in addition to the fact that
functions have the power of being
invoked functions are also capable of
storing properties just like any other
object looking at the diagram again you
could imagine that the function object
that is referred to by the variable car
might have a dot methods property
pointing to the object that we are using
to store all of our car methods it might
be easier to reason about if you imagine
that the car variable stored an object
instead of a function from this
perspective it's easy to imagine how the
dot methods property could be a property
of the car object but I would like to
remind you of how similar a function is
to a regular object in that it's allowed
to have properties just like any other
object it is also important to point out
that there is no interaction between the
properties of a function and what do you
expect to happen when you invoke that
function the invocation of the function
only makes the lines inside the body
execute invoking a function has no
interaction with any of the properties
of that function now you might be
tempted to imagine that because we've
added a property to the car function
some interesting mechanism is going to
be engaged or some rules about how
functions work will start to become
active but there aren't any interesting
rules that will become active as a
result of the fact that we added a dot
methods property to the car function
this is just simple property access like
we've always done but this time it's for
the purpose of decluttering the methods
object out of the global scope all we've
done is moved our methods object out of
the global scope and there's nothing
special about car dot methods other than
that it's conveniently tucked away as a
property of car